We will now continue
with the problem
of inferring the unknown
bias of a certain coin
for which we have a
certain prior distribution
and of which we observe
the number of heads
in n independent coin tosses.
We have already seen that if
we assume a uniform prior,
the posterior takes this
particular form, which
comes from the family
of Beta distributions.
What we want to do now
is to actually derive
point estimates.
That is, instead of just
providing the posterior,
we would like to select
a specific estimate
for the unknown bias.
Let us look at the maximum
a posteriori probability
estimate.
How can we find it?
By definition, the MAP
estimate is that value of theta
that maximizes the
posterior, the value of theta
at which the
posterior is largest.
Now, instead of
maximizing the posterior,
it is more convenient
in this example
to maximize the logarithm
of the posterior.
And the logarithm is
k times log theta,
plus n minus k times the
log of 1 minus theta.
To carry out the
maximization over theta,
we form the derivative
with respect to theta
and set that derivative to 0.
So the derivative of the
first term is k over theta.
And the derivative
of the second term
is n minus k over this
quantity, 1 minus theta.
But because of the minus here
when we apply the chain rule,
actually, this plus sign here
is going to become a minus sign.
And now we set this
derivative to 0.
We carry out the algebra,
which is rather simple.
And the end result
that you will find
is that the estimate
is equal to k over n.
Notice that this is lowercase k.
We are told the
specific value of heads
that has been observed.
So little k is a number, and
our estimate, accordingly,
is a number.
This answer makes perfect sense.
A very reasonable
way of estimating
the probability of
heads of a certain coin
is to look at the
number of heads
obtained and divide by the
total number of trials.
So we see that the
MAP estimate turns out
to be a quite natural one.
How about the
corresponding estimator?
Recall the distinction
that the estimator
is a random variable that tells
us what the estimate is going
to be as a function of
the random variable that
is going to be observed.
The estimator is uppercase
K divided by little n.
So it is a random
variable whose value
is determined by the value of
the random variable capital
K. If the random variable
capital K happens
to take on this specific
value, little k, then
our estimator, this
random variable,
will be taking this specific
value, which is the estimate.
And let us now compare
with an alternative way
of estimating Theta.
We will consider
estimating Theta
by forming the conditional
expectation of Theta, given
the specific number of
heads that we have observed.
This is what we call the LMS
or least mean squares estimate.
To calculate this
conditional expectation,
all that we need to do is to
form the integral of theta
times the density of Theta.
But since it's a
conditional expectation,
we need to take the
conditional density of Theta.
And the integral
ranges from 0 to 1,
because this is the range of
our random variable, Theta.
Now, what is this?
We have a formula for
the posterior density.
So we need to just multiply
this expression here by theta,
and then integrate.
This term here is a constant.
So it can be pulled
outside the integral.
And inside the integral, we
are left with this term times
theta, which changes the
exponent of theta to k plus 1.
Then we have 1 minus theta to
the power n minus k, d theta.
At this point, we need
to do some calculations.
What is d of n, k?
d of n, k is the normalizing
constant of this PDF.
For this to be a PDF and to
integrate to 1, d of n, k
has to be equal to the integral
of this expression from 0 to 1.
So we need to somehow be able
to evaluate this integral.
Here, we will be helped by the
following very nice formula.
This formula tells
us that the integral
of for such a function
of theta from 0 to 1
is equal to this very nice
and simple expression.
Of course, this
formula is only valid
when these factorials
make sense.
So we assume that
alpha is non-negative
and theta is non-negative.
How is this formula derived?
There's various algebraic or
calculus style derivations.
One possibility is to
use integration by parts.
And there are also other
tricks for deriving it.
It turns out that there
is also a very clever
probabilistic
proof of this fact.
But in any case, we
will not derive it.
We will just take it as a fact
that comes to us from calculus.
And now, let us
apply this formula.
d of n, k is equal to the
integral of this expression,
which is of this form, with
alpha equal to k and beta
equal to n minus k.
So d of n, k takes the form
alpha is k, beta is n minus k.
And then in the
denominator, we have
the sum of the two
indices plus 1.
So it's going to be
k plus n minus k.
That gives us n.
And then there's a plus 1.
And how about this integral?
Well, this integral is also of
the form that we have up here.
But now, we have alpha
equal to k plus 1,
beta is n minus k.
And in the denominator, we have
the sum of the indices plus 1.
So when we add these
indices, we get n plus 1.
And then we get
another factor of 1,
which gives us an n plus 2.
This looks formidable.
But actually, there's a
lot of simplifications.
This term here cancels
with that term.
k plus 1 factorial divided
by k factorial, what is it?
It is just a factor of k plus 1.
And what do we have here?
This term is in the
denominator of the denominator.
So it can be moved
up to the numerator.
We have n plus 1 factorial
divided by n plus 2 factorial.
This is just n plus 2.
And this is the final
form of the answer.
This is what the conditional
expectation of theta is.
So now, we can compare the
two estimates that we have,
the MAP estimate and the
conditional expectation
estimate.
They're fairly similar,
but not exactly the same.
This means that the mean
of a Beta distribution
is not the same as the point
at which the distribution is
highest.
On the other hand, if n
is a very large number,
this expression is going to be
approximately equal to k over n
when n is large.
And so in the limit of
large n, the two estimators
will not be very
different from each other.